je les accuse de massacrer la
planèteill et de laisser en prison un
innocent pour le réduire au silence mon
fils est condamné à mort je pe compter
sur
personne'il attaché dans Mass qu'est-ce
qui s passé ilta un village
pigusehu
de partout tout le monde en croque y
compris dans les haut sphèr alors
l'huile de palme on y touche
ce matin la cour d'appel dearta vient de
confirmer la condamnation à mort de
Martin
land moi ce que je veux c'est récupérer
mon
fils ma mère a raison quand on veut
changer le monde le monde laisse pas
faire votre fils se trouve au cur d'un
jeconomique et politique qui dépasse
complètement
[Musique]
son
va se battre on va aller
[Musique]
jusqu'au